- Canada is a really attractive place
to pursue AI because it's a
very supportive environment.
And we're also, as researchers,
very supportive of each other.
- [Samira] We have some of
the biggest labs in the field
and that in general
makes it so easy to start
and grow in this field.
- [Sarath] The entire
deep learning revolution
actually happened in Canada
and we were able to do this
because there was a constant
support from the government
and CIFAR.
- [Martha] The great thing about the CIFAR
Pan-Canadian AI Strategy
is that it's focused on AI expertise.
The funding model in Canada
largely focuses on funding
people rather than projects.
And this means that you're
free to pursue the research
that you think is important.
- [Samira] I like how the
AI community is connected
and works together and
push the boundary of AI.
- [Graham] Well, it's really
a highly collaborative environment
that supports joint projects
and provides resources
to researchers across the country.